- The final guest video in this run
is from Alie and Micah,
a neuroscientist and a clinical therapist
who run Neuro Transmissions.
Their video has giant magnets, 3D printing,
and a Star Wars action figure.
Alie, Micah, it's all yours.
- We're here at the Keck Center
at UC San Diego.
And this is a functional magnetic
resonance imager, or an fMRI.
- Well, functional, but not functioning.
This is actually a dummy scanner
that's used for educational
and training purposes.
An actual fMRI machine
houses a 3-Tesla magnet
that's more than 60,000 times more
powerful than the Earth's magnetic field.
And over 3,000 times more powerful
than your average fridge magnet.
If we were anywhere near the real deal,
well, we would put our camera
and our equipment at serious risk.
- But why on earth would anyone
possibly need a magnet so powerful?
Well, some of the researchers here
at UCSD are using fMRI
to study the human brain
in ways that 30 years ago
just weren't even possible.
- I'm Maggie, I'm a fourth-year
graduate student at UC San Diego.
- My name is Stephanie Nelli,
I'm a sixth-year PhD student
in John Serences' lab.
- We study mostly selective attention
and expectation and other cognitive factors
and how they influence
visual processing in humans.
- My research is about really basic
visual perception.
How do we make sense
of the world around us?
How do we choose, out of
the plethora of things
that are constantly accosting
our visual system,
how does your brain make sense
of the massive amount of information
constantly bombarding it?
fMRI itself was developed
not very long ago,
it's a very new technique,
as far as human research goes.
And it was developed in the '90s, I believe,
actually in Bell Labs.
- fMRI is a particular specialty of MRI
called functional MRI,
so what that does is basically, instead of
measuring the difference
between particular tissues,
you're actually optimising
to detect the difference between
oxygenated vs. deoxygenated blood
in a person's brain.
- For a long time, it was impossible
to look at the brain up close
without cracking open someone's skull.
[Micah laughs]
And even if you got a brain from someone
who's passed on, that's not all that useful
for understanding how it works.
When Leonardo Da Vinci dissected
the human brain in the 16th century
it was with the intention
of finding the seat of the human soul.
Spoiler alert, he didn't.
- Unsurprisingly, the functions
of different brain areas
were essentially a mystery
well after the scientific revolution.
But fMRI changed all that
by giving scientists
the ability to see the
brain working in real time,
track activities in
different brain regions,
and read your mind.
- No, unfortunately not for us scientists,
an fMRI machine cannot read the mind.
It can tell you basically where blood
is being transported to in the brain.
So which parts of the brain are active.
- An fMRI scan can tell you when someone
is doing some cognitive task,
what kind of patterns of
brain activity you see.
So which areas are active, what information
are those areas representing.
For instance, if you have someone look
at different images and you measure MRI
while they do that, then later if you have
that same person come in and you say,
okay, think about something.
Now, based on that information,
I can guess what you were thinking about.
- I could probably say
you're looking to the left
by looking at your neural activity
or I could say you're looking
at a horizontal line
by looking at your neural activity.
However, am I gonna be able to tell
what you're daydreaming about
or who you're in love with
or something like that?
No, I don't think think that's gonna happen
in my lifetime but, you know,
I said it on camera so
we'll be able to... [laughs].
- It might not quite make sense
how a magnet does all of this,
so let's break down the
process step by step.
Let's say that Rey here has been having
some neurologically linked problems
and a doctor refers her for an fMRI.
All of her Force powers
are messing with her head.
"Oh no, Kylo Ren keeps
appearing in my mind!
"I can't stop thinking about his hot torso.
"Ohhh!"
- The technicians place her on the table,
give her some earplugs
and stabilise her head
so she can't move it at all.
If the head moves during the scan,
the images will come out fuzzy.
Next, the table slides into
this large, doughnut-shaped
section which houses the
ultra-powerful magnet.
The strong magnetic field of this magnet
then actually turns the
hydrogen atoms in our blood.
- Wait, what?
- Yeah, the human body has a lot
of hydrogen atoms because well,
we're mostly made up of H₂O, that's water.
The magnetic field from the fMRI interacts
with the protons in the hydrogen atoms
and makes those protons essentially point
in the same direction.
That's right, your molecules are magnetic.
Hence, the magnetic resonance part
of magnetic resonance imaging.
- Once Rey's in position,
she'll hear a series
of very loud clangs and beeps.
[MRI machine beeps repeatedly]
But these sounds aren't
just the hottest new beat,
they actually serve a purpose.
Every clang you hear is a radio wave pulse
being fired off.
This radio wave disrupts the uniform direction
of the protons and pushes them
in slightly different directions.
Here's the cool part.
As the protons move back into realignment,
they release their very
own small radio signal
and those signals are then detected
by the fMRI machine's radio receiver,
which starts taking snapshots
of cross-sections of your brain,
which you hear as the beeping sound.
After some complicated computation,
what shows up on the computer screen
is a series of images that show both
the anatomy of your brain
and highlighted areas
where there's more blood flow.
Pretty cool, right?
- Yeah, so fMRI doesn't actually measure
your brain activity.
It can't detect your
individual neurons firing,
as cool as that would be.
fMRI machines actually detect
what's called the BOLD signal.
- So the BOLD signal stands for
blood-oxygen-level dependent signal
and it's basically an index
of how much oxygenated haemoglobin
is in a person's blood at a particular
point in their brain.
- Neurons themselves don't keep a high store
of glucose hanging around
so that they can do their job
and so the blood vessels,
through these things called
astrocytes, actually,
help supply neurons with the glucose
and oxygen that they need
to do their signalling.
- When you have neural activity
that happens in your brain,
a bunch of blood will rush to that area
and it turns out that oxygenated
and deoxygenated haemoglobin in your blood
have different magnetic properties.
So deoxygenated haemoglobin
will disrupt the magnetic field
more than oxygenated haemoglobin will
and it'll actually cause
a decrease in the signal.
So when you look at an fMRI image,
the higher the signal you have,
the more oxygen is in
your blood at that point.
And so you actually can measure
with the BOLD signal after
these neural events occur.
That basically tells you how much energy
was consumed at that location.
- Now, it's not perfect.
It can't detect changes instantaneously
or tell you exactly what kinds
of signals are being sent.
- But even with its limitations,
it lets us better understand
which brain regions do what.
Using fMRI, scientists have been able
to identify 180 distinct brain regions.
Better understanding the roles
of different brain regions means
that doctors can use that information
to help treat and support patients
with neurological disorders
or brain injuries.
fMRI technology is cool,
but both of us wanted more.
We wanted to get into the machine
and see what our own brains looked like.
Maggie and Steph asked me to participate
in a pilot research study looking
at how humans distinguish between faces
and I jumped at the chance to help out.
- I didn't participate in the study
but I was able to get a structural scan.
It doesn't measure blood flow
but it does give you a high resolution image
of your brain's anatomy.
It was a strange experience, being inside.
It felt like being in a plastic coffin.
I can see why some people
get claustrophobic.
- And participating in the study
was harder than I expected.
While the task I was doing was easy,
it was hard to stay focused on doing
the same thing over and over
for almost two hours.
But it was also really
cool to see the results.
- And yet, we could not pass up
on the opportunity of a lifetime.
- I mean, sure it's cool to see your brain
on a screen
but imagine
holding it in your hands.
What does my own unique brain
really look like?
Well, as it turns out,
we're able to find out.
- Thanks to modern software, we're able
to take the 2D slices of our brains
and compose them into a 3D render
and print them out.
Cue the time lapse.
- Well, look at that beautiful brain.
- I really liked how the rainbow filament
turned out on this.
- Yeah, it's so pretty.
- This turned out really cool.
- I know, and I really like
my glow-in-the-dark print.
It's super bright.
- The grooves are much wider in yours,
and not quite as tightly packed,
whereas mine is super tightly folded.
- It's cool that you
can see the inside too,
the hippocampus and all these
different brain regions.
- Obviously I knew that my brain wasn't
perfectly symmetrical, no one's brain is,
but you can really see
very obvious differences.
It's really interesting to see,
like, oh, that's my brain's shape.
- Right, I didn't really
think about that before.
- Every time someone
comes over to our house
I'll be like, did you see my brain?
- Lemme show you my brain.
- Lemme show you my brain!
- It's incredible that we have
the technology to track the activity
of a live human brain.
fMRI has pushed
neuroscience to new heights
and has given us a glimpse into the seat
of human consciousness.
And only somewhat less incredible
is the fact that we can
use those same images
to build 3D models so we can
create a life-size version
of our own brains.
How funny that just a chunk
of squishy cells this big
can come up with such incredible tools
to help us better understand
our minds and ourselves.
- Huge thanks to Maggie and Steph
from the Serences lab for their expertise
and to UCSD for giving us
access to their scanner.
And thanks to Tom for giving nerds like us
the chance to share our brainy love.
Maybe we'll see you later?
- Maybe?
- Until next time, we're
Neuro Transmissions,
over and out.
- Thank you folks, go subscribe
to Neuro Transmissions.
I would recommend starting
with Micah's video
on training a cat to high five
or Alie's video on how
marijuana affects your brain.
And that's it! I'm back next week
and I will see you then.